je sais pas si elle va venir sur le
plateau ou pas euh elle est extrêmement
encore choquée euh on va voir si elle va
venir ou pas vous allez voir les images
qui sont vraiment dramatique encore une
fois et vous allez voir amori bu va tout
nous expliquer le journaliste police
justice qui sera avec nous également
dans un instant mais euh vous allez voir
encore on va se dire que on marche sur
la tête et on sait pas encore ce qui va
devenir ce que ce qui va advevenenir de
de de ces jeunes filles vous allez voir
c'est ça a été la vidéo du jour et le
bad buzz du jour encore une fois quand
on dit qu'on voit des choses tous les
soirs incroyable euh on va parler
maintenant de gerérard Miller Gérard
Miller vous avez une photo de gerérard
Miller s'il vous plaît merci merci voilà
euh Gérard Miller le psychanaliste et
ancien chroniqueur de Michel Drucker et
Laurent Ruet qui est accusé d'accréion
sexuelle par plusieurs femmes sous
hypnose il est pas chez vos amis lui si
RA mes amis mais il est connaiss je
connais pas t c'est le directeur du
journal la soumission je connais pas
tous ses amis mais bon c'est pas mes
amis mais il est et c'est le directeur
du journal du part il défend beaucoup en
amis ah d'acc moi je connais pas moi je
le connais pas du tout je ne le juge pas
mais en tout cas bon l'une d'entre elle
évoque même un viol on va en parler avec
Anthony qui va tout nous raconter petit
recap de cette affaire de d'un de tes
amis
regarde le psychanalyste Gérard Miller
se fait connaître du grand public en
tenant diverses chroniques médiatiques
je reste convaincu que Mélenchon peut
devenir Premier ministre mais
aujourd'hui une enquête du magazine l
vient de paraître dans lequel le soutien
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon est mise en cause
si l'homme démant les accusation
plusieurs femmes souvent rencontré lors
de tournage l'accuse d'agression
sexuelle et de viol lors de séances
d'hypnose il touchait mes seins sous mon
pull j'ai senti aussi sa main passer sur
mon sexe alors que se passe-t-il on fait
le point ce soir dans
TPMP Anthony rise merci Anthony alors
raconte-nous ce qui s'est passé parce
que c'est incroyable bah il se passe
qu'il y a trois femmes qui ont donné une
interview dans le magazine l il para
qu'il est en froid avec Mélenchon petite
info donc c'est plus votre ami voilà
mais ça n'a jamais été mon ami ça ne
l''est plus ilétaé alors oui alors
Anthony vas-y trois femmes ont donné une
interview dans dans dans le magazine et
elle raconte en fait un peu près toute
la même chose c'est le même la même
méthode opératoire je je dirais c'est
que voilà elles ont été elles ont fait
des séances d'hypnose avec lui et il y
en a une qui l'accuse de viol et deux
autres d'agression sexuelles elle
raconte complètement les faits il y a
une agression qui a eu lieu en 90 un
viol en 93 et un autre en 2004 c'est
incroyable C soire Gill oui parce que en
fait il y a une absence totale de
consentement sous hypnose d'ailleurs
écrit dans des ouvrages vous êtes dans
un état second et donc il aurait profité
selon des témoins il faut préciser qu'il
ni formellement les fa on va le dire
après parce que il a réagi mais déjà on
va raeler on va rappeler les faits voilà
donc il y a une ancienne journaliste qui
parle
d'attouchement une actrice cousin oui
pouvez le citer cousin oui très bien une
actrice Anna moulalis qui avait 19 ans à
l'époque et qui raconte des scènes où
effectivement elle aurait été sous
emprise et une autre jeune femme qui
explique à 19 ans elle a été hypnotisée
mentalement immobilisé donc ne pouvant
pas réagir et selon elle violé voilà
voilà les témoignag la baby cter aussi
qui raconte que un jour il l'a ramené
chez elle et dans la voiture a essay non
mais il y a plusieurs femmes en fait qui
parlent aujourd'hui hein donc clairement
c'est c'est ça c'est toujours le même
mode opératoire c'est il plusieurs
femmes donc un premier témoignage l'une
des accusatrices est donc la journaliste
et autrice Murielle cousin l' faet se
serait déroulé en 90 alors qu'elle avait
23 ans et Gérard mer en avait 42 elle
avait accepté d'être son cobail pour un
article sur sur une séance d'hypnose
alors qu'elle était sous hypnose Muriel
Cousin elle aurait vu le psychanalyste
donc passer sa main sur son sexe
par-dessus son
pantalon traumatisée elle n'aurait pas
osé porter plainte donc il y a ce
premier témoignage deuxième témoignage
une deuxième femme raconte une agression
qui aurait eu lieu en 2004 2004 elle
raconte avoir rencontré le psychanalyste
sur le plateau don don on a tout essayé
avec Laurent rquet qui était le patron
on a tout essayé alors qu'elle avait 19
ans l'émission de Laurent qui cartonnait
on a on a tout essayé il y aurait aurit
proposé de de le rejoindre chez lui avec
une amie à la fin de l'émission pour
prendre un
verre leur aurait proposé de faire un
jeu euh qu'il faisait avec ses patients
un jeu d'hypnose arrivent font un jeu
d'hypnose avec Gérard Miller puis il
aurait passé sa main progressivement et
jusqu'à sa poitrine sur le corps de la
jeune fille avant de l'emmener sur son
lit pour
l'embrasser sa copine a réussi à
s'enfuir mais elle est resté tétanisé
c'est ce qu'elle raconte troème
témoignage une ex babysitur
du fils aîné du psychanalyste raconte
également avoir été victime d'une
agression sexuelle en 93 il lu aurait
touché les seins et aurait tenté de
l'embrasser en laaccompagnant chez elle
en voiture d'autres choses ont été
révélées notamment son comportement sur
les tournages Gérard mer ont également
tenté des approches avec des jeunes
femmes lors des tournages de film des
comédiennes racontent qu'il leur
proposaient des séances d'hypnose
individuelles l'une d'en donc Anna
moulaglis raconte même qu'il l'aurait
menacé de donner ses répliques à une
autre si elle ne participait pas à ses
deses séances euh et donc forcément
euh Gérard Miller a réagi Gérard Miller
est psychanalyste bien entendu il a été
aussi chroniqueur pour Michel Drucker et
Laurent Ruquet c'était un proche de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon maintenant il paraît
plus donc c'est plus votre ami euh
contacté par les journalistes d'elle de
l le psychanalyste a publié un premier
poste sur X deux journalistes du
magazine l m'informment sans me donner
de précision qu'elles vont publier un
article me mettant gravement en cause
dès que j'aurai connaissance de
l'article je réagirai dans les meilleurs
déles ici même il a également indiqué
n'avoir jamais abusé sexuellement
quiconque et en aucune circonstance
récemment le psychanalyste a dû
justifier sur certaines réactions qu'il
avait eu lors d'une interview du
cinéaste Benoît Jacco ce dernier évoqué
ses relations avec de très jeunes
actrices
regardez en commençant à vivre avec
Judith godrch alors qu'elle était encore
mineur c'était clairement une
transgression pour vous oui c'est
forcément une transgression parce que je
ne sais plus ne serait-ce qu'on regarde
la loi telle qu'elle se tel qu'elle se
dit
euh on na pas le droit en principe je
crois donc une fille comme elle comme
cette Judit qui avait en effet 15 ans je
en principe j'avais pas moi 40 j'avais
pas le droit je crois pas mais ça alors
avait rien à et même elle ça
l'excitait beaucoup je dirais alors on
va regarder les les justificatifs de de
de Gérard Miller qui habite à Londres
non maintenant oui alors juste oui je
peux revenir sur l'interview qu'on vient
de voir juste une seconde parce que on
voit non mais en fait c'est les les
plaignantes les jeunes femmes ont vu
cette interview qui date de 2011
ressortir d'accord et dans cette
interview où effectivement le
réalisateur Benoît Jaco parle de sa
relation avec Judith GARCH très jeune à
l'époque Gérard Miller ne rétorque pas
d'une
manière formelle violente et honté il
fait preuve de complaisance si je puis
dire et quand les jeunes femmes ou les
femmes aujourd'hui ont vu ça tout ce
passé dont vous venez de parler cyril a
ressurgi en elle c'est pour ça qu'elle
se manifeste aujourd'hui après les fait
voilà alors regardez sa justification
après il y a une info qui tourne sur gér
minire qu'on va prendre avec des
pincettes que je vous donnerai dans un
instant regardez au moment où ce film
est tourné je suis d'accord avec vous
sur le fait que c'est un interdit on n
pas le même concept peut-être de la
transgression mais peu importe c'est
tout à fait important de comprendre
qu'il y a eu quand même une dimension
d'aveuglement collectif à ce moment-là
et quand ce film pourquoi je ne peux
évidemment pas imaginer le même film
parce qu'aujourd'hui nous ne sommes plus
dans cet aveuglement collectif donc il
faut bien mesurer effectivement ce qui a
changé sinon on oublie qu'est-ce qui a
été révolutionnaire dans Mitou alors euh
donc Gérard miner et euh on va évoquer
donc c'est sa réponse après je vous
donnerai une info voilà qui qui tombe à
prendre avec des pincettes bien entendu
mais qui tournerait dans le métier
Gérard mer donc Nil les fait il déclare
dans un communiqué transmis à BFM TV il
n'y a jamais eu quoi que ce soit qu'on
puisse qualifier d'agression sexuelle ou
pire de viol euh en ce qui me concerne
précisément les femmes qui me mettent en
cause si quelque chose leur a déplu
lorsqu'elles étaient avec moi je n'ai
aucune hésitation à l'affirmer rien de
ce que j'ai perçu ne m'indiquer qu'elles
voulaaiit mettre un terme à la situation
car sinon à l'instant même j'y aurais
mis un terme cependant il qualifie tout
fois ses relations de rapports
inégalitair je sais que depuis le début
du mouvement Mitou des paroles
essentielles ont émergé qui remettent en
cause la façon dont les rapports
hommes-femmes sont constitués dans notre
société sur la base d'une incontestable
domination masculine selon lui ces
femmes n'étaient pas sous hypnose euh
celui ou celle qui acceptit de s'y
livrer n'était absolument pas hypnotisé
il restait parfaitement conscient en
totale possession de ses moyens
réfléchissant et parlant normalement
cependant il reconnaît qu'elles n'ont
peut-être pas pu exprimer clairement
leur refus sans être hypnotisé tout en
restant parfaitement conscient il y a en
effet des situations où celles qui ne
manifestent d'aucune manière son refus
qui répond même oui aux questions qu'on
pause pour s'assurer de son
acquaissement se sent dans
l'impossibilité d'exprimer librement un
désir qui contreviendrait à celui de
l'autre Gill une réaction là-dessus
c'est assez ambigu quand même euh sous
hypnose euh je trouve qu'il ne reconnaît
pas assez formellement que sous hypnose
vous êtes en situation de faiblesse vous
êtes vulnérable vous êtes dans un état
second vous êtes tétanisé quand il dit
rien n'indique qu'elle n'était pas
satisfaite de la situation si elle
n'était pas satisfaite aurait-elle pu le
manifester rien de l'indique non plus
donc je trouve que cette réaction est
ambigu voilà très bien oui oui surtout
qu'il y a quelques années il avait donné
une interview chez Thierry Ardisson pour
présenter d'ailleurs un livre sur
l'hypnose et il expliquait d'ailleurs
très clairement dans ce livre là que en
fait quand on est sous hypnose on vous
fait faire absolument n'importe quoi
vous êtes une poupée vous êtes voilà on
vous fait lever le bras et cetera il
l'exlique très clairement surtout si si
l'hypnose n aucun rapport pourquoi il a
attendu qu'elle soit sous hypnose pour
leur proposer des relations sexuelles il
avaent leur proposer dans la vraie vie
sans sans hypnose donc là on voit bien
qu'il y avait quand même une manœuvre
qui était quand même de en tout cas on
verra ce qui devent de d'encore un autre
donneur de leçon on verra bien sûr on
suivra cette affaire et un donneur de
leçon qui est au cœur de de de cette
polémique on verra un petit peu comment
ça avance en tout cas mais petite info
il paraîtrait jour sur des castings où
il était très très relou avec les filles
il paraîtrait je donnerai le nom demain
il paraîtrait qu'il ait un comédien
assez connu qui lui aurait mis un gros
coup de pression voire l'aurait un peu
violenté pour lui demander d'arrêter et
d'arrêter d'être lourd c'estap prendre
avec des pincettes mais on vérifie
l'info mais apparemment l'info circule
et je vous donnerai le nom du comédien
si il est avéré demain ce comédien qui
voilà qui s'en est pris à lui parce
qu'il en avait marre qu' embête et qu'il
emmerde les filles sur les tournages et
qui se comporte euh bizarrement avec les
femmes sur les tournages voilà donc
écoutez on verra bien ce qu'il en
devient de ce qu'il en advient de de de
ce donneur de leçon